SAM DUTTON: Enter
the land of Lie-Fi,
and find out why Jaffa
the Cake thinks you
should give a developer a hog.
I'm Sam Dutton, standing in
for Rob, who's on vacation.
Lucky man.
Take a journey
with Jake Archibald
as he cranks up web speed via
smart markup, service workers,
and much more to get
from good to great.
Catch a glimpse of qute
furry animals along the way,
and find out how
to handle Lie-Fi.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
I call it Lie-Fi.
Offline is OK.
At least it's honest.
Can I fetch this?
No.
Can I go here?
Can I do this?
No.
SAM DUTTON: How the Streams API
will save us all from slowness,
and, as Jake advises,
discover what
to do next time a
developer shows you
something they've made.
Interactive WebGL
infographics synchronized
with media playback.
This stunning site counts
the cost of conflict
from World War II
onward, and it's also
an optimistic reminder
that many of us
are lucky enough to live in
a relatively peaceful world.
Beautifully structured
and produced.
Check it out.
Now meet Chris
Lowis, audio guru.
He's written a detailed
article about how
to synthesize drum sounds.
Everything you
ever wanted to know
about building your own 808
to sample or to synthesize.
The mighty Web Audio
API lets you do both.
And before you know
it, you'll be partying
like it's 1982 all over again.
Code and demos included.
Filling in forms on the web.
Don't make me think!
Forms are extra-hard
to get right on mobile,
and this little article
gives ten short tips
for a better user experience.
Labels, fonts, tap
targets, input types.
There's also a bonus
tips, but you'll
have to read the
article for that.
Tooling is too damn complex.
PAUL: To get going with
the web first, install npm.
Then probably install Bower.
And then we're going to
install Gulp or Grunt or both.
And then--
SAM DUTTON: Whatever
happened to Hello World
and the simple accessibility
of web development?
Paul and Jake slug it
over two pints of IPA,
and Jake explains how he
destroyed his headphones.
And finally, are you
bored of the web?
Had enough hacking
JavaScript, CSS, and HTML?
Well, you need to get back
to BASIC, the language that
maybe sparked of the programming
boom and the whole demo scene.
GOTO loops, the PRINT
command, syntax errors,
and floats that are
faster than integers!
Yup.
Learn how to program
for the Commodore 64,
the highest-selling
computer model ever.
So that's a wrap for
this week, folks.
And here's a little
something for all LazyWebbers
to feast your eyes on until
Rob Dodson returns next week.
Thanks for having me.
Thanks for watching.